[Music]
thanks for coming bye everybody
my name is Greg Heysel I'm a CTO at
astronomer astronomer our goal is to
pretty much help companies adopt Apache
airflow and we use kubernetes to do to
do a lot of that so today I just want to
talk about kind of quick overview of you
know airflow and kubernetes for anyone
you know kind of learning - learning the
ropes there talk about running air flow
at scale and was I mean that some of the
major design considerations just to kind
of think about if you're gonna be you
know pushing this out of your company
and just some of the things that we've
learned along the way as we've kind of
built this service up on top of air flow
so what is air flow it's a task
scheduler written in Python to
programmatically author schedule and
monitor DAGs so several people on this
track of already kind of mentioned air
flow and even the kubernetes piece the
last talk so that's kind of cool so the
groundwork is laid it's also a top-level
Apache project as of a couple months ago
some impressive stats so real quick just
the kind of the core concepts of air
flow for anyone unfamiliar DAGs are kind
of the big thing there's a picture of
one it's deities created in code which
is important for for air flow it's one
of the differentiating features between
it and some of the maybe some of the
workflow engines that do a declarative
kind of approach to workflows a dag run
is you know an instance of that dag
running in time so typically these these
DAGs are scheduled on a cron crontab
kind of syntax every night at midnight
every hour and that kind of thing when a
task instance is just you know an
execution of one of those nodes in the
graph during a bag run so there's kind
of like the core concepts of air flow
I'm not gonna dig too much into air flow
kind of more geared gearing this talk
towards the kubernetes side of things
couple screenshots here so there's just
the dag view this is just a stupid
little dag I'd do demos with just prints
the date and sleeps here's another view
of airflow just the tree view kind of
shows the dag you know running over time
here's a little screenshot of the log
viewer so as you're kind of writing your
DAGs you're pushing code things break
inevitably this is a good place to go to
kind of see why a task failed hopefully
it has this code view so here's what I
meant by you know bags or code it's just
Python code you kind of just you know
use the air flow library string tasks
together and define the dependencies so
I mean now these days air flow has been
around for quite a while a lot of
companies obviously have been
integrating it into their stacks these
days I mean it's gotten a wider kind of
view of use cases of a lot of it was
kind of geared towards ETL use cases now
ml is kind of becoming a bigger a bigger
use case so orchestrating like training
and publishing models and that kind of
thing
higher usage so now that it's kind of
been ingrained into companies a lot more
people are using it it's their you know
new engineers come on they get trained
on it it's just kind of part of the
culture these days stricter SLA is you
know once you know the way it goes you
know you build up a POC you get it out
there and then all of a sudden the
company's running on it so things get
more important over time so the SLA kind
of becomes an important factor and then
just just immutable infrastructure it's
kind of you know coming onto the scene
it's kind of like the standard way to
deploy things these days so that kind of
there's a little bit of a challenge just
from the way that things were
traditionally done with air flow up
until as of recently so so air flows you
know a highly highly available
mission-critical
thing now that people need to think
about so if that's the case there's kind
of a checklist of things here's a cup
that you may want to have kind of
knocked out before he before you start
relying on it so just a way to automate
air flow deployments so I should have an
easy way to just spin spin up a new
airflow tear an airflow down kind of
just you know typical stuff there so I
also want to be able to push code all
the time
engineers are always iterating on
airflow tags so as it's part of the
culture you know people gonna be pushing
more code hundreds of tasks or executing
a day thousands of tasks you know a lots
of Engineers pushing code if that's the
case you probably have some questions
around security and access control who
can who can do what with airflow or
which airflow and then the observability
aspect of things so how do you keep
track of what's going on externally from
air flow so if air flow goes down how do
you know or what's going wrong with it
and then auto-scaling
so we have some great tools these days
and you don't always have to be on
anymore so you can kind of dynamically
scale scale things like a cluster
according to what's going on it what
needs to be done so real quick
kubernetes if you haven't heard of it
I'm sure everyone's heard of it but now
it's a portable open source platform for
managing containerized workflows or
workloads typically with you're working
with kubernetes you're going to be
writing yeah Mille walls and walls of
yeah Mille so just real quick yeah so
this is just a screenshot of gke
Google's managed kubernetes but you know
the typical way you do things now is you
know you split you split your
application up into you know isolated
chunks called micro services and you
push those out on kubernetes so a couple
of core concepts of kubernetes real
quick before we dive in pod one or more
code located containers they kind of
share things like volumes and ports
deployment is a higher level abstraction
that can manage those underlying pods
which is we'll get into some of that and
why that's important staple set
that's just like a deployment the only
difference is you have a stable hostname
and persistent volumes so there's pods
spin up if they went down they'll mount
that same persistent volume that they
were that they were using before daemon
set a pod just gets replicated to every
single node in the cluster and a
namespace is the official definition is
a virtual cluster backed by physical
cluster so there's a tool called helm
it's pretty popular with if you've
worked with kubernetes it's a great way
to kind of manage all this yeah Mille so
if you're writing yeah Mille over and
over again and you want to kind of
abstract things out to find little
chunks you can reuse here and there home
is a great way to do that it also
functions as a package manager for
kubernetes so you can helm install just
like you pip install you npm install or
anything like that and those and that
can deploy that can manage you know a
whole suite of micro services pretty
easily so comes a great tool so let's
say I've been working on say I have an
airflow cluster and an air flow chart
that I've developed an air flow chart is
just a home package so let's say I have
you know uh my yeah Mille oh my you know
my charts kind of living locally how do
I get this thing running on kubernetes
you just home install give it a name
point to the chart if it's locally just
locally residing otherwise there's a
whole suite of stable packages that
already exist out there in a central
repository so if I do a helmet stall and
I spin up all these different you know
components that you know make up an
airflow cluster what am I actually
deploying out to that cluster and that
kind of depends on and a lot of cases
which airflow executors you want to use
so kind of talked about a little bit
here earlier some other talks but an
airflow executor is just a pluggable way
to kind of distribute the airflow
workload so when it's time to run a task
you know the executor kind of determines
where does that run
you know where's that task actually run
couple options exist this sequential
local or local executors that's two
different ones there as mentioned in the
previous talk you know they just fork
off if it's time to run a task they just
you know fork out of a sub process run
the airflow run sub command and pass it
the you know the the parameters that it
needs to do its thing that task runs and
that process dies and you know keeps on
going so it's good for definitely good
for simple workloads obviously a lot of
people have had a lot of success taking
that pretty far especially with some of
the newer things like a kubernetes pod
operator which we can kind of get into a
little bit but eventually you know
sometimes things will eventually need to
scale out real quick that's just kind of
what if you were running the local
executor on kubernetes its kind of it
looks like pretty simple just have a
kubernetes deployment managing a pod for
the web server the airflow web server
and the air flows scheduler we typically
use an external kind of manage Postgres
so I was kind of depicted like that but
those two things living in a namespace
kind of happily running nice and simple
all the tasks executing on that
scheduler right there so the traditional
way up until you know not too long ago
to scale out air flow was to use the
celery executors celery is a distributed
task queue written in Python backed
typically backed by either a Redis or
RabbitMQ there's a couple other options
there the point is there's a dependency
there you have to kind of manually
manage the number of workers that you
want to have running as well as the
worker size and that's that's kind of
becomes a problem you know when you
start talking about auto scaling and
scaling to zero and those got things but
either way it works just fine on
kubernetes so this is what that could
look like if I did a home install this
chart and I said give me that give me
the celery executors same things going
on at the top air flow web server
scheduler running the difference now is
we have a Redis dependency
and then we also have the airflow
workers which can be you know obviously
like a you can configure the number you
want you can have twenty whatever and
those could be however big you want to
make them you know however much memory
CPU you want but they're always on
unless you use a kubernetes horizontal
hot a horizontal pot autoscaler but even
so it's still low tricky so the next the
newest executor to hit the scene is the
securities executor again talked about
that and passed in the previous talk but
big advantage here in our opinion is you
can scale to zero or near zero zero ish
each each task runs in its own pod and
you can kind of configure dynamically
depending on what that what that actual
job is doing you can kind of configure
you know X CPU X memory so you can kind
of customize that on your cluster it's
really nice its fault tolerant so what
it does is you know as this thing is
running its subscribed to the kubernetes
api event stream as tasks are finishing
it's getting notified of those events
and checkpoints where it is and that
stream as it's going along which which
is really important and I'll get into
that here in a second the great thing is
that all these pods you know if you have
a whole bunch of tasks running and the
scheduler goes down well those pods will
still keep running running to completion
they're kind of uninterrupted by you
know what's going on with the scheduler
which is great
straightforward natural there's nothing
in between there's no queue there's no
you know any extra infrastructure you
have to manage just to do this so with
airflow if you work with air flow before
you know there's a couple different ways
you kind of ship your code around one
way with the kubernetes executor to do
this is to do a on a knit container get
clone you know your dag files into a
local volume before you run
you could also mount the shared volume
where those those Python files happen to
live or my favorite you can just
use the same you can just kind of
repackage your code into a into an image
and then use that same image for all
your tasks so we're probably gonna talk
a little more about that one here in a
second
so this is what the kubernetes executor
looks like if it's doing nothing just
like the local executor let's say it's
time to run a task what happens under
the hood the executor makes a call out
to the kubernetes api running on the
master says hey I need to run run this
pod and gubrious does what it does and
runs the pod so that the command that
gets run inside that pod kind of like
the entry point of that pod is just the
airflow run command that would normally
be forked off and run in the sub process
or run in the celery queue in the celery
workers so so that works and then you
know if you're running a bunch of tasks
you know you can just kind of keep
launcher pods up until you hit the
ceiling of possibly a resource quota
which you can set on the namespace so
part of what you can do with the
namespace is kind of set those upper
limits so if you want a particular
airflow deployment to be constrained you
know you don't want it to cannibalize a
cluster you can say hey you know I only
want X amount of pods to be able to run
in this namespace or X CPU and memory to
used and kubernetes will reject the pot
if if those quotas are kind of being hit
so a good way to keep keep an eye on
things learn that the hard way with
mazes so you know if we have an a
running air flow deployment out there
that infrastructure we just kind of
looked at there you know how do you how
do we update how do we update the DAGs
how do we push new codes so people are
pushing code every day every hour in
some places how do we do that so back to
helm here so the you know with helm
there's a concept of like passing in
variables that can gonna get templated
into your Y amyl into your deployments
so here I'm just kind of hypothetically
setting this this tag variable when I do
this upgrade so I'm saying up
this this helm truck that I that I just
installed except this time for that tag
variable which is presumably associated
with an image name let's bump it up 200
- you know it's the second time we're
going to deploy this we have a new code
we have a new dag or we made an update
what happens under the under the hood
here is that you know that the helm
upgrade will run it'll update the the
state in kubernetes so kubernetes is
backed by an LCD cluster to persist its
state kubernetes will kind of do the
heavy lifting here do a do a graceful
termination on anything that's kind of
looking at that that tag so in this case
I would say that you know the the
scheduler in the web server should get
rebooted with that new tag so if they
were running version 1 they're gonna
gracefully shut down that version 1 and
bring up version 2 and both of those
pods
if task 1 and 2 are out there running
while this happens like we mentioned
before it's no problem those tasks will
run to completion
you know kubernetes will be aware of
that event and then when that's
scheduler boots back up it's gonna Reese
absque Ribe to where it left off in that
kubernetes event stream and say hey ok
task 1 and 2 finished or they didn't and
they're still running in which case it
doesn't matter so and then you know from
that point on any new tasks that are
scheduled by that version 2 image can
just be launched with the version 2 code
so the dag the dag should exist there
the cool thing about all this is that it
kind of fits into just the way that
people deploy modern software can fit
right into CI CD pipelines so typical
scenario we see is you know people push
up to master or cut a release of their
air flow code that could trigger a build
on whatever pipeline system you happen
to be using at the end of that run your
tests push up a new image to a docker
repository final step helm upgrade to
the to the latest version and let
kubernetes take you from there so you
know how do we how do we monitor this
thing so it's always good to have like
an X
kind of monitoring system you want to
just rely on airflow to tell you what
air flow is doing so again this is just
a bunch of suggestions these are just
things that we've done and had a lot of
success doing there's a million ways to
do things with airflow but we think
these are pretty good pretty solid ways
to do these things especially on
kubernetes so one way to do it is with a
tool called Prometheus we could just
helm install that pretty easy prometheus
it's also a cloud native Foundation
project just like kubernetes it's a time
series database under the hood also has
this kind of pool based metric system
where we'll actually go out and scrape
targets that you tell it to grab those
metrics and then stash them in this
database there's a great plugin works
flawlessly with kubernetes to plugin so
it can do automatic service discovery
which is great by default and
out-of-the-box airflow is emitting stats
D metrics so Stach these a little
different than the Prometheus world
stats T is more of a push based system
so it's if you configure air flow to
push that ste metrics it's gonna
actively push you know send these
metrics out on an interval to to some
external server that doesn't quite fit
with how Prometheus is set up so the
folks at Prometheus actually have the
stats D exporter component which is kind
of nice it can act as a bridge so you
can point that make that thing your
stats D endpoint you point airflow at
that and say hey Sunday metrics there
that thing will in turn you know store
those in memory and expose them out on
an HTTP endpoint for Prometheus to
scrape which all surprisingly works
pretty well out of the box
so with Prometheus this is kind of how
this looks in practice a little a little
deeper we have Prometheus out here
running as a stateful set meaning it has
that persistent volume if you reboot it
kick the pod down bring it back up it's
going to remount that same volume which
is good and then it will use its service
discovery mechanism we kind of mentioned
earlier
it will pull the kubernetes api and say
hey give me any services give me any
kubernetes services that have these
annotations on them so you can kind of
say okay if a service is deployed to
communities and has you know this this
Prometheus scrape annotation defined on
it will start scraping it starts craving
it for metrics and it'll keep it'll keep
track of a lot of these things like
labels which are great for this next use
case so you know maybe I got a dev
server that's my that's my dev cluster
it's been out there running we've been
iterating for a while now it's time to
install another airflow for my team to
use maybe it's the prod one or just
another team in general just isolating
themselves with another airflow home
install boom this whole infrastructure
goes back out just the same that new
service is deployed out there prometheus
automatically becomes aware of it and
starts scraping it and ingesting metrics
and now it's ingesting metrics from two
air flows you just keep doing that it
just kind of keeps on working so this is
kind of some of the this is a you know
one view of some of the metrics that the
scheduler is emitting just and this is a
griphon dashboard so Griffin is a
dashboarding tool it works pretty pretty
great with Prometheus out of the box you
can see you know for instance there you
can kind of sort things out by the
labels so if I have a bunch of air flow
of deployments I got three kind of
listed here I can kind of drill into
those for instance and kind of zoom in
this is another screenshot of you know
some of the stuff that you know we do in
practice we were kind of aggregating
some metrics from the scheduler itself
we also integrate some metrics from some
other tools like this cube State thing
that just kind of gives you status of
pods just kind of keep an eye on things
and we're also pulling some data we like
to deploy we like to deploy air flows
with a PG bouncer which is just like a
connection pooling thing to kind of sit
between it in the actual database so we
can keep an eye on just how many
connections air flows using especially
when things are scaling out yeah pods
run all over the place it can get a
little unwieldy
so we we're scraping metrics on that too
we kind of pull them all under this kind
of
- bored no just another look we're also
pulling CPU memory keep an eye on things
pod statuses everything running so after
metrics you know logging is the next
kind of big thing on the observability
kind of ticket there airflow has you
know some of this stuff built into
itself with this log there's this log
viewer the typical the local executor
kind of works out of the box you know
it's nice and easy it just kind of
writes the the log files you know down
to the the scheduler and then the web
server knows kind of where to look for
those files if you ask for it the
problem is when you use the kubernetes
executor you know those tasks are
running those pod logs exist you know
the the task logs exist in that
container what happens when that
container is gone after the task runs
you know we gotta figure out something
else there so airflow be an airflow it's
got a lot of pluggable kind of
interfaces so the logging is no
different so it has several kind of
remote backends for logging available
it's got you know let's see an object
store for the big three clouds so and
then an elastic section I'll kind of
looking looking closer at both of those
here that's yeah just zoom in on that so
so in the case of you know using one of
the the object store backends for the
logging what kind of happens here is
kind of the bottom first here you know
as those task pods are running out there
they're just kind of normally you know
writing out their log file to the local
the local filesystem that gets kind of
scrapped when the container goes away so
watch if you can figure with this the
object store one of these object store
backends before that container ships
down it'll take care of uploading that
file up to whatever bucket you know you
point your your your airflow at and then
if you go into that web server you click
on a task and you want to drill under
those logs you know it all it does that
webserver just makes that requests out
to pull that file down and then just
displays it in the web browser
another option is elasticsearch it's a
little more involved
so it's you know if depend of depends on
the use case but we use it so I thought
I'd talk about it a little more here
this is what this could possibly look
like it's a little crazier but you know
the the left there is this a normal
airflow deployment that we kind of had
we've kind of seen running before on the
right here is a different name space
where we have all this elasticsearch
stuff kind of running the way the way we
can do this we actually have a PR I kind
of listed at the bottom there that we're
actually working on or wrapping up to
kind of allow some of this stuff but if
you configure the elasticsearch log
Handler with our new option we have a
new option for JSON output enabled and
standard out output instead of writing
its task files down to the file system
it'll actually just spit those those
task logs out to the standard out of the
the pod that's actually running that
task and then from there we can kind of
rely on some of the kubernetes again
this is just you know we can we can rely
a lot on what kubernetes does by default
here so by default queue Bernays will
actually take anything coming out of
standard out stream those down to the
actual host nodes you know it's like if
our lib containers something something
where all these log files exist we can
run a fluid D daemon set so you know a
pot affluent deep pod running on every
single node can also mount that volume
and kind of start sucking in all those
logs and shipping them up to the the
elasticsearch clients to be ingested so
a little more involved there one
advantage of doing this is that if with
the object store kind of method those
task logs are not uploaded till the end
of the task so if you're trying to debug
maybe a running task or something that's
been maybe it's stuck or looks stuck you
know you can't really check it out live
until the end so that's just kind of one
cup one of the shortcomings
I guess the object store with with the
elasticsearch plugin it's actually nice
it's great because it'll actually be
kind of those like a live polling thing
where it'll actually run query like
every second you know looking for new
logs and then string this down in real
time to the web interface so you can
kind of actually as as things are
happening in real time you can kind of
debug those which is one of the big
reasons we kind of opted to go this
route for our kind of standard
deployments and it also has the
advantage of you know the rest of that
ecosystem you can set up Kabana on top
of it and do deeper deeper log analysis
if you want to so one of the last things
I want to talk about here is kind of
this authentication and authorization
piece so airflow by default I think it
has an LDAP plug-in I haven't used it so
I'm not too sure on how that works but
if you're integrating this into your
company you know you wanted to become
more you know native to what your
company's doing there's a couple options
again this is very much an opinionated
view so this may or may not work for
some folks but one way to do this with
kubernetes is to leverage these things
called it an ingress controller so an
ingress controller or an ingress in
general it's just how you expose a
kubernetes service to the outside world
so if you just launched these pods out
into kubernetes but you wanted to get to
them from the outside world
you kind of need this ingress object and
there's ingress controller to kind of
help you do that so the way you utilize
this we use we've kind of standardized
on nginx ingress it's a very well
maintained open-source version of an
ingress controller there's a there's
like five or six more pretty popular
ones out there differing feature sets so
you gotta you kind of have to look at
that
the reason we went with nginx early on
was that it was one of the first to kind
of support this this concept of like an
external authorization
server so we are rolling with that right
now this is kinda what that looks like
so this slide got a little crazy I kind
of ran out of room and started not
drawing things but on the left there we
have this nginx ingress controller
deployed so which just it just gets
deployed like any other kubernetes
service usually you run this thing with
like an elevated with elevator
privileges it has access to poly the
kubernetes api and pull down metadata
about what's running in the cluster so
it's very similar to how that kubernetes
or the the prometheus plugin does
service discovery using annotations this
ingress controller is actually watching
that API is waiting for these ingress
objects which is kind of that thing with
the drop shadow under it over there it's
waiting for those those objects to get
submitted to the kubernetes api and it
looks the ingress controller just says
hey you know we've submitted an ingress
could an ingress object they want me to
expose this thing to the outside world
under this domain and it'll it'll kind
of take care of doing that the the
Internet's ingress controller is kind of
exposed as a kubernetes you would you
would give it a type of load balancer so
that it it is actually exposed to the
outside world from typically one of the
managed cloud providers have a load
balancer solution that kind of fulfills
that so like Google has like you know
their global load balancer system that
it kind of ties into and all the other
clouds kind of have their own
implementation but once traffic hits
that nginx from the outside world it
kind of takes care of routing it to the
to the to the backing services and then
ultimately the backing pods so what's
going on here is you know it's watching
for ingress objects to be submitted all
the time
let's say a request comes in you want to
see someone's logging in they want to go
check the logs on an airflow tag so
that's that's that's traffic you would
consider from the outside world
typically so that's coming into the
cluster as that request is coming in if
you have this this ingress configured
properly you can say hey any and you
requests that come in forward them down
to this authorization server and if that
server returns it 200
I'll let the roll forward the request
down downstream if it doesn't return an
error message or something like that one
thing I didn't depict here because I ran
out of room was you know a login page so
part of this ingress part of the
specification for these ingress is in
addition to the off server you can also
say well if it's if you return an error
code you know where do I go to login you
can point it to redirect over to some
some other site that you Ron and this
could be discrete things like auth0 octa
you can kind of integrate with those
kind of tools to actually kind of
fulfill you know a lot of the
authorization heavy-lifting so the way
we do it is we we issue a JWT our
authorization server issues JWT s so
JSON web token that web token was
encoded contains a you know a couple
important bits of data we are in the
process of kind of integrating what we
do in terms of our back down into some
of the stuff that you know airflow has
this new this new piece called
you know I think like the are back
dashboard basically it's like air flow
has introduced you know the ability to
grant certain users the ability to look
at certain things or trigger certain
actions so that's new and they're more
recent versions of airflow we're it we
we have written a security plug-in so
this is all just using stock air flow
stuff we can have to hack anything this
just fits right in we wrote a little
security manager plugin that sits you
know it's just Python it's configured
with the air flow web server we just say
hey you know this is our security
manager plugin point to the class that
exists in the image and when that
request comes in we can use that
security manager we can read that JWT
decode that read some of that
information and what we do is we embed
role data and some some some additional
user data but the important part is a
role so we can say any role that lives
up at the astronomer level which could
be
in your companies which you know that
could be anything that's completely
custom you could pass that down and say
whatever whatever I exist as in my
company you know pass that down this
thing could make the decision to say
okay let's translate you into you know
just an airflow viewer or just an
airflow editor or maybe you have full
full op privileges which you can you
know complete complete control of the
airflow cluster so that's kind of how
we're handling that's a lot but you know
this is like the probably the ultimate
flexibility in terms of you know kind of
handling these this stuff on kubernetes
with with airflow so getting towards the
end here this is I just didn't fit in
the category so it's a special mention
here but this is a there's a with the
kubernetes executor there was also this
kubernetes pod operator introduced so
instead of just running you know the
airflow tasks as you normally would
using this like the standard plugins
which you can do is actually launch a
custom image that can do something
totally different it could run java code
or code or you know whatever you want so
what we see as we hoping companies adopt
airflow is if they have some crazy
dependency that doesn't doesn't it
clashes with their normal code or just
as a pain to deal with otherwise we say
hey just make your own image build over
there and then just host it somewhere we
can get to it or give us a password or
give us the docker login to get to it so
we can pull it down and not just
unleashes you know the you know you can
do whatever you want and that in that
scenario
so again airflow super flexible kind of
allowed us to kind of build all these
different integrations on top of it and
really customize it we build it build a
platform on top of it so that's all I
got
thanks for swinging through
I want to ask a little bit about the are
back um so are you saying that like you
with the astronomer level are back it
actually takes advantage of air flows
are back and like does that actually
allow for like multiple tenants to be on
the same airflow instance like securely
hmm
we don't do multi so we don't do multi
tenant with it it's typically just one
tenant as an attendant being like an
organization or a company so the way
that we do it is we you know we have we
have an API layer that's kind of houses
you know some astronomer level stuff
that fits into our UI fits into our
ecosystem so in the astronomer layer you
can kind of go in you can say hey I want
this person to be you know an owner or
an admin or just a viewer at the
astronomer layer that could mean that
means that kind of wraps into the
deployment thing so if I'm just a viewer
on a deployment you know I wouldn't let
you I wouldn't let you push a debt I
wouldn't let you push an image up to the
repository and therefore propagate it to
the running cluster so there's a couple
things that we want to handle at our
layer but then we also want to leverage
that same system and just propagate it
down into airflow so that you know we
can essentially map our rolls down into
airflow rolls where we can take
advantage of some things at our layer
while also letting people use the native
stuff in air flow thank you so just
comment on that one actually so so our
first ship with half of its security
manager so basically its extent for the
fab security manager so I believe like
astronomer also pure astronomer secure
manager which extend fo secure manager
so that you can all write certain or
permission management code so that you
could stick to multi tenant manager
[Music]